hello YouTube just lovers in defense
this is guns in here now when you play
d4 you expect your opponent to play
either Kings Indian defense or the
Queen's Gambit decline or the Slav
system but how often you have to face
this move which is e 5 this will be the
case especially when you are playing
quick chess or the bullet chests people
who play e5 are two kind of people the
first one are very attacking people
probably attacking mania where they
wants to sacrifice a pawn for the rapid
fast development and the second kind of
people are very lazy people who actually
do not want to study the theory of the
big openings and just want a quick
recipe get out of the opening now the
problem from the white perspective is
White knows this opening is unsound but
somehow if you least expected this
opening and especially if you are not
prepared against this opening then there
are every chance that you get wrong in
this opening so join with me and learn
how to defuse this tricky gambit now the
good points are I have covered every
single systems of the black
and added bonus to that we have a
universal system so it will be easy for
you to remember to defuse this campaign
okay here I certainly recommend we
should take this fall so D cross e Phi
and here black has a two genuine reply
now as usual in my video I will cover
the sidelines first and the first
sideline we are going to cover is this
move which is b6 now this is known as a
black Bernhardt lob gambit and here what
black is expecting is why to take the
pawn so the bishop comes out very much
freely a black has a very free piece
development for a-1 pawn
well certainly white will be not as much
as cooperative and here I want to
mention one golden rule now whenever
black offer the second pawn you never
take the pawn so please remember this
you never take the second pawn unless
and until there is a specific
compensation okay here I am recommending
you play Knight to f3 now if you
opponent play Knight to c6 then it will
be deviate to a male line but the
most-played
other move is Bishop to g4 now idea is
very simple black wants to capture the
night and then he wants to regain the
pawn well here you play Bishop to f4 so
developing a piece with defending upon
and here there are two good replies from
the black if black play Knight to c6
and we will play Knight to c3 where at
first sight it looks like White has
given up the pawn so for example black
can take this Knight and after he cross
f3 black can't regain the pawn but the
whole idea of the white is to get a very
good positional advantage so why do we
continue here with the Queen to e2 so
now you can see two pieces are attacking
the pawn and the most logical reply from
the black will be Bishop to d6
afterwards White will castle on the
Queen side now you can see the advantage
of the white so not only why it has a -
open file to work out the attack but why
it has a bishop pair to boot so I'm not
going further from here onwards you can
analyze by your own and all I can say
it's a very good position to play as a
white okay the other good move black can
play at this point is Bishop takes f3
and there's a very tricky idea by black
so when wide we capture the wisher black
can play this attacking system starting
with the move g5 now you can see it's
attacking the bishop and the once the
bishop goes to the g3 black and play
this move which is Bishop to g7 now you
can see this bishop is spinning this
pawn so if white take the pawn then the
rook in the corner will be hang after
Bishop Crosby - but why it has a very
good reply which is taking the pawn and
calling the black bluff and of course
black will take the pawn so Bishop takes
b2 and the idea of the black is if white
take the c7 pawn so for example D cross
c7 then black will simply exchange the
Queen and after King recapture black can
play knight c6 and as far as I can see
white will be a piece down so what is
the whole idea of capturing the pawn
well I give you a few seconds can you
find amazing mordor where you can win
outright
okay of a more start with the move Queen
to e2 plus and now black has a to reply
if the King goes to the d7 then the
simple answer will be Queen to b5 check
and you can see white can nab the bishop
so that's not possible and if most
logical reply but the black will be king
to f8 but here
first we'll grab the pawn so you can see
now it's attacking the Queen and the
knight and the only sensible reply is
Queen to see it but afterwards Bishop
check and King to g7 White has a
a complete reputation move which is
fiend to be file and see is as so many
threads over here the first thread is
wide wants to capture the bishop the
second thread is white
any movement white can capture this
Knight and third which is the most
dangerous one which is Queen wants to
capture this pawn and that will leads to
the checkmate so for example if black
foolishly take the rook then this leads
to checkmate
so that leads to the only reply left for
the black which is Bishop goes back to
f6
but now white can simply grab the knight
in the corner and after rook takes again
we take the rook and after Queen takes
white can play c3 and you can see white
emerge with a rook up in this position
so this is one of the good trap exists
in this line
please remember this trap if your
opponent play g4 and Bishop to d7 okay
so that is a one side line which can be
occur in this opening the male line
start with the move Knight to c6
and again we'll play Knight to f3
now here Black has a three genuine reply
let's take out the rubbish first so the
first move black and play is this move
which is Knight G to e7 and this
variation is known as a Zoomer much
variation which the name has been given
after the famous USA chess player
the idea is very simple Knight wants to
go to g6 and regain the pawn and black
will emerge with a superior position
here I am recommending a universal
approach start with the move Knight c3
so you will see this move often against
all the system from the black the
general line continues with the Knight
to g6 so now two pcs are attacking the
pawn but White has a very very good
reply which is Bishop to g5 the most
logical reply of the black will be
Bishop to e7
but after Bishop takes Bishop Queen
takes Bishop White has a stunning reply
which is Knight to d5 it's not only
attacking the Queen but it's also eyeing
at that c7 square where Knight can folk
the king and rook so the black has to
forcefully retrieve the Queen to d8
White has set up a trap over here so for
example any Knight can capture the pawn
then after we'll exchange the one pair
of night and after black recapture White
has a very good reply which is Queen to
c3 now you can see it's these two pieces
are attacking the c7 square and not only
that this queen is also attacking the
knight and the most logical reply of the
black will be Knight backs to c6
but then g7 Hanks and
Queen will simply take the pawn and
after rook to f8 at least white can have
this move Knight to f6 and where the
black King will be misplaced and please
note in this position white is born up
so it's completely unplayable for the
black so the most logical reply here
after Queen to d2 is to Castle by the
black well against this you can also say
this is one kind of blunder move by
black and the very good reply of the
white will be Queen to g5 and now you
can see not only it's attacking the
Queen but now this c7 pawn will be
unguarded you can see we have by this
models we have completely refute the
zubur much variation and that's why
nowadays nobody play this variation the
second move second response of the black
at this position will be to play again
gamba ting the pawn so starting with the
move d6 and hoping that White will take
the pawn well against this White has a
very aggressive plug with start with the
move Bishop to g5 and you can see
it will be a very very hard struggle for
the black and here black has a four
reply let's look at each by turn if very
initial Bishop to e7 then afterwards
we'll take the bishop and after Knight
captured Bishop we can simply grab the
pawn so this is one of the case where
you can grab the pawn and you can see if
the Queen we capture the pawn then we
can capture the Queen and then black
will have isolated pawn so in one of my
game my opponent plays C cross d6 but
you can see not only black has created a
weakness on d6 but what is upon up so
what will we have a good game from here
onwards let's took the other option
where instead of Bishop to e7 black can
play this move six but again we can
simply recapture the pawn and if the
knight takes f6 then white will be
simply a pawn off for nothing and if she
cross f6 then simply we can play Bishop
to f4 and a simple line runs like this
so in one of my game my opponent played
Knight to e7
I played Knight to c3 he played Bishop
to b6 I played efore and after Queen to
d7 Queen to d2 he castle king's Queen
side a nice I Castle queenside
please note there is no need to go
opposite side castle because white is a
point up so all you need to do is play
it safe action PCs one by one and at the
end you will be upon hub and see right
now at this position not only white is
upon off but black has a shuttered pawns
on the kingside so initially I won this
game
so that will give you a rough idea how
you can handle these positions now
instead of f6
black can play this move which is Knight
G to e7
but again against this we can simply
capture the pawn and after black
recapture we have very much easy to play
plan so we have a ready-made target over
here and I have shown by the arrows how
we can exploit this so for example this
Knight can go to I from c3 to B file
this Bishop can come to therefore and
then Queen goes to d2 and the rook comes
to the d1 and all the pieces will lining
up the d6 and that b6 will default
sooner or later so that is Knight G to
e7 and if black does not want to
surrender his pawn structure then black
has to play this move which is Queen to
d7 good made about the Queen to d7 it's
hanging on to the pawn but the bad thing
is this bishop has been locked in so it
will take an ages to come out and this
will be a very good compensation for the
white so for example here we certainly
take the pawn and after Bishop to d6 we
can play Knight to c3 and after Knight
to e7 this has happened in one of my
game
Blade II for my opponent castle on the
kingside i played Bishop to d3 and after
Knight to g6 I played castle on the
Kings side and after Knight f4 Bishop
takes Bishop takes g3 and Bishop to d6
Knight to d5 you can see how long this
Bishop was in prison because of this
stupid queen and not only that white
emerge with a pawn up now the third
option for the black will be Queen to e7
and this variation is known as a England
gambit now against this White has a some
of the very good reply starting with the
move Bishop to a4 and Bishop to g5 but
here I propose you play Knight to c3 and
again just like in our last variation
after black recapture the pawn this time
the bishop on f8 will be in prison so I
show you one of my game which will give
you an idea or how you can exploit this
one of the slight advantage of the white
tier I played efore my opponent
responded with the Knight to f6
I played Bishop to f4 so now two pieces
are attacking the knight he simply
defended with d6 but after Queen to d4
please remember this Queen deployment
because not only our queen is
centralized
but our three pcs are attacking the
knight so finally my opponent give up
his central line with my passive looking
light so i recapture with the G pawn and
please note at this position if you upon
and place C file then our Queen can go
back and we can castle on the Queen side
and targeting this d6 square so very
obviously my opponent play Bishop to d7
but after I castle on the Queen side to
harder he realized that he cannot go to
the queenside because the it a 7-point
hanks so he chained the plan and he
played g6 but you can see the why
development is so much good and black
king is stuck in the center all just
because of this stupid looking queen is
7 and here I converted my development
into the winning potential so here I
played right to be Phi attacking the two
pawns so my opponent captured the night
and once I recaptured the bishop he
played c6
but this is a big mistake and I give you
a few seconds can you explore a winning
continuation by the white
okay the meaning continuation of the
white start with the move e5 and please
note that cannot capture the bishop
if black foolishly captured the bishop
then we have e cross d6 so now you can
see our queen is attacking the knight
and also upon is attacking the Queen su
Queen has to go only one square but
after this we have rook H even check and
after King to d7 we have a very amazing
reply which is rook to e7 check and
black King will not survive longer
so that's why bishop takes is impossible
in the game my opponent plays D cross e
Phi but after that I do capture with the
bishop and now you can see two pcs are
attacking the knight and here he first
given me a check I don't know what's the
difference it makes I park marking in
the corner then he played Bishop to g7
after a few calculation I found out this
amazing continuation I give you a few
seconds can you find amazing
continuation for the white okay let's
start with the move Bishop to d6 and now
you can see the Queen cannot come to the
e6 otherwise it will be a pinned against
my rook so my opponent play Queen to d7
but after rook edge even check King goes
to the only square which is d8 I played
this move which is again rook to e7
he played clean - fi but after Bishop to
c5 if my opponent play is nice to defy
then the bishop on on the g7 will hangs
and afterwards Luke on the h8 will hang
so my opponent decided to play King to
c8 but after that I played this move
which is Queen 26 now I'm threatening to
give a checkmate on c7 and after the
last move he played Knight to defy I
simply snap up that night
and here we design so this is a one
system which solves me very well and the
good thing is it's very easy to learn
and it's very easy to refuse and many
lines you can see not only why it has a
good position but white will remain upon
up I hope you enjoy and learn how to
defuse this tricky gambit feel free to
comment and I'll make you soon bye